- I used be the smartest.
Made sure I was the
smartest guy in the room.
Now, if I'm the smartest guy in the room,
I'm in the wrong room.
- You're in the wrong room.
- I believe in this
philosophy of do it now.
99.9 percent of the people
are zeroing themselves out,
they're doing 28 days a month, not 31.
(whoosing)
- Need motivation?
- Watch the top ten with Believe Nation.
- What's up Believe Nation?
It's Evan, I believe in you,
and this channel is designed
to be a part of your
daily success routine,
so let's get your motivation to a ten
and get you believing in you.
Grab a snack and chew on
today's lessons from a man
who went from starting with nothing
to becoming a millionaire by age 32,
going broke, losing it all,
and then gaining it all
back again and more.
He's David Meltzer,
and here's my take on his
top ten rules of success.
(upbeat music)
Okay, let's kick it off
with rule number one.
Shift your energy.
- You can think, and say,
and do certain things,
and believe certain things,
but if you carry an energy it's different.
It doesn't matter what
you're trying to manifest.
Let me give you an example.
There's a lot of people
that date the same person
again, and again, and again,
or they have the same business problem
again, and again, and again.
Same obstacles.
No matter what they do you seem to,
"Why, why is this always happening"?
It's cause you carry an energy.
- I agree with that.
- So what I analyze, and I went to India
and kind of learned this stuff
about myself is number one,
my siblings were all
hyper-intelligent students.
They all went to the Ivy Leagues.
So I kind of had a chip on my shoulder
that I didn't go to
Harvard, Penn, or Columbia.
My siblings were much more academic,
so I had that going, then
when I was little I was hyper,
and they were good students.
My grandma who, my mom was a teacher,
would take us after school
was this wise old, kind
of Yoda type of character.
And, she would always say to me,
I would go, "Grandma, I'm
bored, I don't want to study!"
She goes, "Only stupid people get bored.
Smart people think of things to do."
Well this changed my cellular memory,
my neuro-pathways, and
into my code, my DNA.
So my energy shifted.
What did that mean though?
That means I projected my
insecurity about being stupid.
Made me an ego driven guy.
Who then surrounded himself
with the wrong people,
and I used to be the smartest,
made sure I was the
smartest guy in the room.
Now, if I'm the smartest guy in the room,
I'm in the wrong room.
- You're in the wrong room.
- Rule number 2, Do it now.
- The second thing is,
I believe this philosophy of do it now.
Which kind of realms on
this whole congregate like,
"Hey, can you introduce me right now?"
Immediately, when
anything's come to my life,
I ask myself, "Can I do it now?"
So, "Hey, can you refer this?"
"Yeah, hold on."
I'll make phone calls.
You've been in meetings with me.
It's like almost ADD, but it's not.
It's just, talk about saving time.
Anything you can do now,
you at least saved twice as much time.
The minute you don't do something now,
it'll take you minimum
twice as much time to do it.
Plus you got to remember it,
plus you can become
statistically unsuccessful,
exponentially unsuccessful
the longer you wait on it.
So, I actually have now,
on my Do it Now strategy,
not only do things now, but have a folder
which is called Do it Now,
so it's things I would do
now if I was capable of.
Something that's that important.
So, I immediately after I'm doing it now,
and doing this, I'll go
to my Do it Now folder,
so I won't forget.
And those are the important things.
So I have this system of doing it now,
which only saves me time,
and makes me more
statistically successful.
- Rule number 3, Survive Failure.
You're story to me, really is one of
being able to rebuild,
and so few people, A, can do it,
and, B, the one's that can and have
don't want to talk about it.
So, how do you think about failure?
How have you conceptualized in your mind,
why are you able to
talk so openly about it?
- You know, I did an
interview with Ryan Leaf,
and we were talking about big failures,
and his failure was even
more public than mine.
But, the number one shameful
thing of losing everything,
and the most courageous thing
was to face our mothers.
- That's interesting.
- You know, you talk about the public,
and I said today, I had
Sheriffs line up at my
Rancho Santa Fe home, and moving trucks
to take everything out.
33 homes alone in San Diego, gone.
Golf courses, Ski Mountain,
so beyond my community, and associates,
and all of this, and I was
already working for Lee.
This is from past transgressions.
I was already on my path
and journey of fulfillment,
but the hardest thing was to
walk through my mom's house,
and, I get choked up,
and I had to tell her
not only did I fail myself,
but I felt I failed her.
It was really, really tough.
So, that failure, to me,
was the toughest part.
So, for me, all the other things
were just learning experiences,
but I had to get over the shame of that.
Here, they took my mom's house.
My dream of getting rich
was only to buy my mom a house and a car.
You know, I grew up with nothing.
Six kids, single mom, so for me,
to make it back, I was
already on that journey,
and I felt as if I could
stay in a place of giving
and faith, and I mean faith in myself,
and faith in the universe,
faith in others of service,
that everything would come
back to me, and it did.
- Rule number four, Don't
take anyone's advise.
- You went to Tulane Law School.
- Yes, Sir.
- And you graduate there,
and within nine months tell
them what happened to you.
Cause I want you all to
hear the ups and downs
of real life business, and real life
from one of the most successful
people in the country.
So, what happens at law school?
- So, I was out of law school,
I have two choices for jobs.
And it's the recession.
One was to be a real lawyer.
Oil and Gas Litigator.
You know, big money.
All I want to do is be rich,
it's why I went to law school.
And then the second was
to work in the internet.
And, I got offered a job to
sell legal research online,
by West Publishing.
Big, big legal publisher.
And so I go to my mom, cause
you'll appreciate this.
I go to my mom, "Hey
what should I do mom?"
My big advisor, you know,
I grew up with a single mom, six kids,
and she, without blinking, is like
"You need to be a real lawyer
cause this internet thing is a fad."
So she calls the internet a fad,
and I always say, cause
I like to teach lessons,
biggest lesson of my life was
just because somebody love you
doesn't mean they give you good advise.
And, I see so many people,
entrepreneurs, in relationships,
they ask for advise for people
that don't know anything.
My mom's a second grade teacher.
What does she know about technology.
- Beautiful sole, but
not a technology expert.
- No, and if I would have followed,
it would've I think slowed down,
or at least not allowed me to
have the acceleration I had.
So, I took the technology job.
Single, money hungry, in a
sales job in the internet.
- So, be very careful,
just because you love
them or they love you,
of thinking they have
some expertise in an area
that you don't.
They probably don't.
So often times we take
advise from the wrong person.
Derails our dream, so that's lesson one.
- One more thing too.
We end up resenting them which is worse,
so all the people we love the most,
we end up resenting them
because they gave us bad advise.
And meanwhile, we should be accountable
because we asked the second grade teacher
for internet advise.
That's the worst part.
- Rule number five, Practice gratitude.
- I tell people today, "If
you want to change your life,
it's as easy as two simple words.
Thank you."
In fact, the best habit that you can have,
I've done research for the last ten years,
in quantum physics, meta physics, physics,
and I will tell you the
best effective habit
that you can have is to say
thank you before you go to bed,
and when you wake up.
If you can say or think thank
you before you go to bed,
and say it and think it when you wake up,
for 30 straight days,
I guarantee you it'll change your life.
How many here think you can
do that for 30 straight days?
Invariably, everybody raises their hand.
The saddest part is by tonight,
half of you will not
say or think thank you.
By the morning, another half of you
will not say or think thank you.
And unfortunately, in three
days, almost all of us
will forget to say thank you.
I've given you the easiest way, gratitude,
to change your life,
and yet we're so far in our own way,
we can't even say thank
you for 30 straight days.
- Rule number six, Ask big.
- You might as well do as
many good deeds as you can.
Open as many doors,
smile at as many people,
hug as many people as you can,
and then when you create void
of giving in service, ask big.
In this human vibration,
this pragmatic world,
ask big, ask for it all
cause it will come to you.
And that's, I think,
something I did subconsciously
when I was 25 right out of law school.
And it's something I do
consciously, subconsciously,
and unconsciously now.
I ask to empower 75,000 people.
I want to change the world
to make people happy.
- And who are you asking that of?
- The universe.
So, whatever you believe
in, whatever you believe in,
I don't care if it's God,
Jesus, Mohammad, Joseph Smith,
the 12th man if you're a Sea Hawks fan.
I don't care, but ask.
Ask the universe, ask who you think.
Put it out there.
You know, there's three ways.
You got what you think, say, and do.
That's one way to put it out there.
Subconsciously, the
neuro-pathways in your mind.
40,000 of the same thoughts.
Put it out there.
And then finally, your energy.
Your DNA, your fingerprint on life.
That's what truly puts it out there,
and that system of
conscious, to subconscious,
to unconscious is what allows you
to truly attract rapidly and
accurately what you want.
- Rule number seven, Provide value.
- We're goal oriented people.
- Yes.
- We played sports where
it's all about winning,
and so what I used to do is I'd attach,
"once I graduate high
school I'll be happy,
I get a scholarship to
college, I graduate."
All this, and every time it occurred
I still was in the same state of mind.
What I learned to do was
to attach the happiness,
this bliss from the outcome.
Now the difference is
most people get concerned,
"How can you be motivated
without an outcome?"
No, no, no.
I have outcomes, and I pray every morning.
This is a truly abundant thing.
My first prayer every morning is,
"My God put in front of me
ten people that I can help."
- That you can help, that you can help.
- That I can help, and I've
shifted the paradigm of value
understanding outcomes and happiness.
So, I used to, and maybe
you'll understand this.
I'm a great salesman.
- You are.
- I can oversell, backend
sell, and lie to you.
I can cheat you.
I've done it when I was in my 20's.
I would shade the truth, you know.
I sold stuff, and it
didn't make me feel good.
What happened was, I created a void
for me to fill all the time.
I'd make you promises, and
I'd live on this premise,
"I'm going to exceed
everybody's expectations."
That's my goal, right.
First of all, talk about bullshit
How many times have you actually
seen, in a business deal,
exceeded the other parties expectations.
Very rarely.
- Very rarely.
Especially if you've
set those expectations
artificially high.
- Which I did.
- The way you exceed
is by not setting them.
- Right, by not charging or selling,
and that's what I started doing.
But, what was cool was, I
started with this prayer,
and then I said, "What if I
started the day with this energy
that God put a whole bag
of hundred dollar bills in front of me,
and my job all day long
was to trade hundred
dollar bills for twenty."
So, whatever I did, I was
going to provide value.
As a father, as a husband,
as business partner,
as a partner, as a philanthropist.
You'll see I ask everyone
either unconditionally
"How can I be of service?"
- You do.
You said it me the first time we spoke.
- How can I be of service, I mean it.
- Yeah, I know you do.
- I know that that's my biggest blessing.
I'm not lazy.
I wake up at four a.m.
I work really hard for others,
but I also, when I work hard for others,
I have my intention, my
focus on what I want.
- Rule number eight,
Focus on being the best.
- Let's say that you want to be
the best fitness trainer in the world.
I don't know if that's reality,
but let's just say you
want to be that trainer.
Okay, would you like to be
the best trainer in the world,
and make a shit load of money,
or just be the best trainer?
- First option.
- Yeah, the money comes so it's not about,
what's not about the money.
That's not my end goal.
I don't attach the money as my goal,
I attach my consistent, persistent pursuit
of my potential of being the best trainer.
I guarantee the best trainer in America
makes a shit load of money.
You know, Bill Parsons is
one of my favorite coaches.
He got into coaching not to make money.
John Madden, you know who he is?
- Yes.
- John Madden got into
coaching not to make money,
but putting his name on EA Sports,
on Madden, he makes more
money than anyone else
for his name.
But, it's not about the money,
why does he do it?
Cause he helps so many
people with that money.
The universe rewards you.
Money's just an energy.
- Rule number nine, Be consistent.
- There's a consistency that
makes people successful.
What happens is we lie to ourselves,
and I'll use health cause
you're and expert at it,
but I see this in
nutrition and in exercise.
People will tell me after one month,
"Gosh, why did I get incremental results
or no results at all?"
I said, "Because you zeroed yourself out."
The kids that showed
up during spring break
to the event that I had.
The one's that were there,
and they had a lot of other distractions,
they're the ones that don't zero out.
They're the ones that get the exponential
power of the universe.
Meaning, if I do something every day,
day one I get x to the first,
day two to the second,
third, third, fourth, fifth.
Most people, when it comes to nutrition,
they're always day six
they zero themselves out.
Then they start over first, second,
and during a month, they
may zero themself out
three or four times.
At the end of the month
they didn't get the exponential results.
If you stick to something everyday,
this idea of being more interested,
really asking the extra questions,
going the extra mile,
which is completely empty in my opinion.
If you want no competition in your life,
go the extra mile.
99.9 percent of the people
are zeroing themselves out,
they're doing 28 days a month, not 31.
- And rule number ten,
the last one before a
very special bonus clip
is be radically humble.
What is something you wish
you knew when you were 21?
- Oh, that's an easy question for me.
Two words.
Radical humility.
I wish somebody would've
taught me the ability
that I didn't know, and it's
the biggest problem I have
with my interns and young
associates at my business,
you don't know what you don't know.
So, feel good about asking for help.
Asking for help is giving
a gift to people like me.
You know, when you ask for
help you become an investment
of that person.
And then, don't forget,
like you said earlier,
just cause you don't have a
lot of money or experience
doesn't mean you can't help that person.
So, if someone would've told me, "David,
be radically humble.
Ask for help, and then
provide help to others."
That's my signature teaching tool here is,
"Hey, ask for help and then follow up
with what can I do for you."
- Now, I've got a bonus clip from Dave
on how to be authentic
that I think you're going to really enjoy,
but before that,
it's time for the three
point landing questions.
Time to move from watching
another video to taking action
in your life or your
business, so here we go.
Question number one.
How can you shift your energy to positive
in your morning routine?
Number two.
What is on your list that
you need to do right now?
And number three.
What are you grateful for?
Who are some investors
that you have learned from,
and have helped you?
- Great question.
So, Steve Wynn was one for me
that's been a great mentor.
Just understanding the relationship
and the energy to money.
(mumbles) the transparency
of how to get to the point.
I used to be an over
seller, a backend seller,
even you could say a,
oh I hate to say this,
but a bullshi...
And, I thought that I
was fooling everybody,
and Steve Wynn taught me,
"I'd rather people hate
you for who you are,
than love you for who you're not."
Because if it's not there yet,
they're going to let you know,
and on the backend, the
truth always comes out.
So, especially as an entrepreneur,
just tell the truth.
As painful as it may be,
because they may have a solution
and they're going to most of
all trust you and help you
beyond in the backend, having
to backend sell someone
because you oversold them.
- Raise your standard
- Apple at the core.
It's core value is that
we believe that people
with passion can change
the world for the better.
- Not one drop of my self worth
depends on your acceptance of me.
- If you want more Dave,
check out the live one-on-one,
hang out interview that I did with him.
There's tones of value there.
The link is right next to me.
I think you're going to enjoy it.
Continue to believe,
and I'll see you there.
- There's two things that,
two schools of thought,
and two ways to go.
One is simply stimulate interest.